Several years ago,
I was teaching one of my Bible classes and a really important and significant book
in the lives of most evangelical Christians came out.
And it created a firestorm of conversation, waves of controversy,
and all kinds of things happening in the Christian world.
The book was Love Wins by Rob Bell,
and I had all kinds of parents asking me if we were going to read it or demanding
that we don't read it.
I had students asking me about it, so I finally said enough is enough,
I need to figure out what the story is.
So I read it, and I used it as a discussion point for my students.
Now, the book had an incredible way of bringing up some really,
really important topics to discuss.
But what was interesting was that the students seemed to really gravitate toward
what the book was suggesting.
That we somehow have this endless sort of chance by chance,
or chance after chance cycle of getting to God.
That if we don't, if we miss it the first time, we'll get a second try at it.
And that the idea of hell is really not all that accurate.
Now,
it's an interesting conversation piece and something that we ought to talk about.
But the Bible is pretty clear.
Now, we've talked about the reliability of this text,
and Jesus is really clear that hell exists.
But it's so easy for our students to want to discount that because we don't
necessarily want to be held accountable to our actions.
And we don't really want to face the consequences. Who wants to face consequences?
So the questions often asked me, like, okay, well, what is hell like?
I don't know. It's probably not nice. I don't really know.
I don't know if I want to know.
It's not God.
Hell is the tragic consequence of rejecting God.
So to help your students understand what this tragic consequence would be like,
the intro experience takes them through sort of a mini journey of imagining the best
possible place,
the favorite place, why you love it, describe it, even put pictures in there.
And then remove all of its goodness, everything.
Cross out any word that has good meaning.
Remove all benefits from that place, all value, all joy, refreshing qualities,
all of it.
What would that place be like then?
And that should help them get into that space of what hell would be like.
I often describe it to students of think of it this way.
Common grace is the grace that God provides all of us, right?
The fact that God is sustaining this world, every breath that I take,
the sun that is shining,
the air that is blowing, the trees growing, all the rain that falls,
all of the things that happen on the righteous and the unrighteous are all common
grace
because God is here, active in moving in history
and participating in sort of sovereignly taking care of this world.
Now remove all of that.
And God is not doing any of that.
Can you imagine what it might be like to not be able to take a breath,
to not have the sun shining, to not have this earth sustained by Him?
Uninhabitable.
It's kind of the way I try to paint a picture for hell for students
to give them that sense of like, oh, God is doing all of this for me
whether I choose Him or not, right?
So then the question comes, well, wait a minute,
how come God sends good people to hell?
How come God sends anybody to hell?
Well, the short answer is God doesn't send anybody, we send ourselves
because we choose to not want Him.
You know, I've often said even that God honors our choices
and allows us to choose not Him and then gives us that very choice.
So this week, small groups as always, but this week especially is super important
because all that we're talking about is sort of going to come to a bit of a
culmination
in the sense that how can a God that we've already said is good that's allowing evil
and all those kinds of things,
how can He then have the existence of hell be alongside that, right?
If God is so good and so loving and He allows this kind of evil,
and this is the question that's been posed to me several times,
is if God allows evil and allows the suffering to happen
and He's so good, then why would He have hell as a punishment for not believing?
Almost seems like there's a contradiction, right?
So these are some of the questions that your students may bring up or some version
of.
Again, open discussion.
If a student is not sure about hell, invite the discussion, invite the dialogue.
Don't shoot them down and just point to scripture and kind of thump on the Bible
like, well, this is what the Bible says.
Well, yeah, and we've talked about the reliability of the text
and the authority of what's in there.
But hell is a very,
very real reality that can be difficult for some people to deal with.
So be patient with your students as you bring them along if they're not quite there
yet.
Allow them the time to process it.
And then small groups are going to be one of those times where that's going to
happen.
And again, it's understanding that God wants us to choose Him.
God wants us to be with Him.
God invites us into relationship.
He does not force us.
And that is love in action.
I want you to be with me.
Imagine being married to somebody that you love that doesn't love you back.
That doesn't seem to make any sense.
Well,
you made it through this week and you've almost made it through the rest of the
year.
We continue to pray for you here and we continue to pray for your students.
And I hope that through this process of looking at hell and evil and suffering in a
very,
very real way
has helped your students understand not only the point of suffering
but the character of God a little bit better
and that not only that this points to the existence of God in some sort of
philosophical sense
but that even in the midst of suffering God is right there with us
feeling the pain along with us.
I hope your students have a better picture of who God is and who Christ is
and what their salvation means and all of that.
You have four more lessons to go.
Now would be a good time to take another inventory of your students and where they
are.
Go back to some of your original notes about how your students started off this year
and how they were around Unit 4.
Where are they now?
And you got some students that have made some decisions.
I hope and pray that you have.
Do you have some students that still have significant questions?
If you need to take some time and revisit some of those questions
either as a group or individually or in small groups, whatever you need to.
Don't rush this process.
You've got four lessons to go.
All of which are going to focus on wrapping things up
and tying up some loose ends
and helping to send your students onward and forward into the world
with greater conviction, with greater confidence and with greater courage.